- [Narrator] Middle ground
is a social experiment
that brings humans
with opposing beliefs
or experiences together.
Remember to seek out
experts and to be critical
of your own biases while
forming an opinion.
Please see the humanity
in each participant,
and as always, we encourage empathy.
(dramatic music)
- (news broadcast) He hasn't prepared.
- (news broadcast) Russia
invading is (beep) psychotic.
(Putin speaking Russian)
(multi media extracts)
(dramatic title music)
- Please raise your hand
if you agree with the prompt,
"I am proud of my country."
Three, two, one.
(computer beeps)
- All that Ukraine is doing now,
we are defending and we defend very well.
Also, I'm proud of my president
who didn't leave the country.
And also I'm proud of all the Ukrainians
who are really connected.
- I've never had these like
unrealistically good
perceptions about my country
because my, personally,
my family had a situation
when we all suffered
because of corruption.
That's, was and is a
big problem in Ukraine,
but this situation definitely made me
feel very proud of Ukrainian people.
- So I'm really interested
in Sergei opinion.
- I can explain myself.
I distinguish the state and the country.
For me, the state is waging the war
and the country tries
to show the best in it
for tens of thousands of people
who come out to the streets of Moscow,
St Petersburg and other cities,
knowing for sure that they will be jailed.
Some of them are badly beaten up.
Some of them jailed for years.
The risks they're taking are enormous
and they know well they're doing it
without hope of changing anything.
But they're doing it for the sake
of showing important symbols
that not everyone agrees with the war.
And I actually think
most of Russians disagree
with the war.
The problem is that they are frightened,
they are isolated,
they're being threatened.
And that makes me proud to the extent
that these dissident
movement is totally hopeless.
but nevertheless, people
are choosing this.
- Thank you for explanation.
It means a lot.
In your opinion, I will agree.
So I will too support people in Russia
who really are against the war
and against of everything happening
who has like clear mind.
I support them too.
Thank you.
- Can the disagreers unmute themselves
and join the conversation please?
- Yeah, I just, I completely
agree with Sergei.
I am not proud of the government.
I'm not proud of the government's actions.
But I am proud of people who are here
and who I know are good Russian people
and who I hope are the
future of this country.
- No matter what happened this year,
if you ask me the same question,
let's say one year ago or five years ago,
I would have the same answer.
I am not proud of my country.
It never cared about regular people much.
When I see at what kind
of lives people have here
especially after traveling
to a few other countries,
I simply cannot say that
I'm proud of my country.
Seeing that my babushka,
my grandmother is having a pension
that is lower that minimal wage
and minimal possible
amount of money to survive.
Of course, we have a lot
of good sides of Russia,
like the guys say, people.
But talking about do
I like it here or not,
about the state?
No, not at all.
- It would be irresponsible
for the US to get more involved.
Three, two, one.
- In 1994, Ukraine gave all
their weapon, nuclear weapon
from their territory.
That was a document between
United States and also Russia.
They needed guarantee to be defended.
If every, if something
will happen like this.
Now it happened,
but Ukraine still asks all the countries
for the weapon.
If we have weapon to defense,
if there are any invaders coming,
we could defense in a proper way.
- United States cannot be a bystander.
And it is not a bystander,
by supporting the Ukraine,
the Ukrainian resistance.
And of course it would
be irresponsible not
to be involved, for the United States,
particularly given what
has already happened.
- I understand why NATO soldiers
are still not in Ukraine
because that can trigger
a very dangerous button there in Russia.
So I understand why no one wants
to take this kind of risks.
When we know one person, Vladimir Putin,
who can press the button
and everyone on this
planet is going to die.
But I agree that it would be irresponsible
to just leave things as they are.
- I'm gonna just throw a
follow up question in here.
Is anyone here concerned about
nuclear weapons being used?
- I'm not sure.
I think that there's this
power of Putin and his button.
I think it's looks like more than it is.
We see that Ukrainian
soldiers are doing their best.
They are excellent in their job
but there is a lack of weapon.
- I think it should be not only weapons,
but also humanitarian help,
like given food to the regions
who are under attack
currently or occupied.
So yes, soldiers, it is super risky
because it will be seen as an act of war
from other countries towards Russia.
But it should be, should
not be only weapons.
It should be something
for the people who live there as well.
- In occupied territories
Russians do not let
humanitarian help to get in.
There is a lot of humanitarian help,
but they do not let them in.
They are killing civil people.
They're killing volunteers.
Just that person who wants to help.
I think only like a weapon
and only hard decisions could help.
- I'm concerned, concerned about
Putin threatening the world with nuclears,
because we already seen Russian military
being in Zaporizhzhia and Chernobyl
which was very dangerous situation.
I believe that it can be just threatening,
just act to scare us.
But also months before the war started
Putin kind of tried to scare the world
that he will start the war,
but promised he wouldn't,
and he still started.
- My life has changed since the war began.
Three, two, one.
(computer beeps)
- Actually my life and
I think lives of all,
almost all Ukrainians
are not just changed,
they are crashed.
On the February 24th,
I wake up from the lightening and
from hearing the sounds of bombs.
I had about, I dunno,
one hour
to gather my all things that I need.
And now I really need to start my new life
from the beginning.
- I had to leave Ukraine too.
The fact that I cannot just come back home
and I also had to pack very fast.
I, to just a little stuff.
I just wanna come home and hug my parents.
I want to make my parents leave Ukraine
and they don't want to leave.
I'm worried about them.
I don't think any Ukrainian
now has the same life.
- Everything pales in comparison
with what Ukrainians have to go through
and how their lives have changed.
However, many people who hail from Russia
had their whole life changed as well,
in a different way.
As a lawyer, I was doing
cases against Russia
with, in the European
Court of Human Rights.
And as a direct consequence of the war,
Russia was expelled from
the Council of Europe
and the whole litigation
in the European Court of Human
Rights is now meaningless.
A lot of people, including
myself, have to leave Russia.
For me, it was important to leave
because I don't want to pay
a cent in taxes in Russia.
It's a small thing, but
it is important thing.
- First of all my mother lost her job
because she was working
for international company
and they are not able to
transfer money right now
to Russia due to sanctions.
But I was not able to find a lot of meds
that I need and I had
to order some of them.
And while they were coming here,
I had to live without them.
My girlfriend, she's American,
and she used to help me to pay for them.
Now she can't
because there's no way she
can transfer money here.
And I, myself, I can't afford them.
- I think that Ukrainians,
even who leave their country,
I don't think they feel safe.
We know examples when Russians
beat bartender in a bar
because he was on the Ukrainian.
We also saw the rally that
supports the war, in Berlin.
- We need to find a place where to stay.
We have these thoughts,
not like what to do today.
We need to think, where do we sleep?
What do we eat?
How do we make money?
A lot of people came without documents
and they cannot even get
international passport
or even Ukrainian passport
because embassy doesn't give it.
A very close friend
tried to escape Ukraine,
but through Russian border.
And they would have to go
through a lot of block post.
One Russian soldier asked him
to give his sneakers to the soldier.
- And that's actually why
the Russian army is losing
because if the army starts marauding,
if the army starts stealing, it's done.
You never win when you're
stealing from the locals.
- We all had this illusion that we live
in the new age, in the new world
where human rights are above everything.
And now we just see that
this is not how it is,
and wars are not the
leftovers from past century.
It can still happen.
And this, just as a phenomenon,
makes me feel very unsafe.
- I live in St Petersburg city.
And since the very beginning of the war,
I had some concerns
about my personal safety
in terms of getting trouble
with laws and with police.
I've joined quite a few protests.
So I also filmed it and
made videos on my YouTube
and TikTok channels.
And I was expecting
that I would face a risk
of getting fined or
getting some jail time.
And I kind of accepted that small risk.
Eventually I will leave Russia.
I came back to Russia two years ago
and I planned to leave Russia in like one
or two years from now.
And perhaps I'll have to leave earlier
but I'm not leaving ASAP.
- And I'm actually also
from St Petersburg.
I think there are two problems.
One, when you have problems with law
then you will not be allowed to leave.
It will be too late.
And second, in one or
two years, in my opinion
there will be no opportunity
to leave altogether.
The border will be closed.
Frankly, if you really think about leaving
and you have opportunity to do that,
do it yesterday.
- I am immune to propaganda.
Three, two, one.
- The trick that's
propaganda uses very often,
sometimes they do not even
show the actual narrative
and try to make people believe that.
Sometimes they just start
telling many different stories
to create this impression
that people cannot trust anyone.
And this is a very
powerful trick, I think.
- I tend to compare
propaganda to junk food.
It's easy to access.
It's easy to consume.
It makes you happy for a while.
And of course you are obsessive with it.
It kills doubt in people.
It gives them clear road view,
which is very easy to live with.
Doubt, which should exist for
research, for understanding,
is also very difficult thing to live with.
So paradoxically, people
who consume propaganda
are happy to keep consuming it,
like with junk food.
And that's why I don't think I'm immune,
as well as I'm not immune
to junk food unfortunately.
- Julia, Niki and Sergei, is it true
that in Russia all the independent
TV channels were closed?
- Now, yes.
Now there are no independent
TV channels at all.
And there are no independent newspapers.
The only independent
journalists left in Russia
are actually foreign correspondents.
And there are few and fewer of them.
- The only way to go for something
that's not like from the
state, is to go online.
And even then you have
to be super careful.
- And use VPN, yes.
There are some medias
that were not only closed.
They were banned online.
- Yeah, I have a friend in
Russia, when everything started
she just posted her like champagne life.
You know, I like ask her,
"Why you don't post anything
on your social media?"
And she said, "I'm just a small person.
What can I do?"
And that is like the worst
answer that can be for me.
'Cause these two months showed
that people are doing something like,
even in social media when
you say your opinion,
you like make seen your voice.
It influences the situation.
It can influence on bigger organization
when people raise and say something.
- A war between Ukraine
and Russia was inevitable.
Three, two, one.
- There was no underlying
reason for the war.
It was started by actually,
basically one person.
- Yes.
The fact that that person
met no resistance for years-
- I disagree that there was no resistance.
There are tens of thousands of people
who spent time in jail,
who are in jail right now,
for daring to protest.
There have been journalists killed
who tried to come out with the truth.
There have been activists
pushed out of the country
or detained, or beaten,
or actually murdered.
So the resistance was there.
Unfortunately it was not successful.
- Like my grandparents, they are like,
"Yes, it's good that Russia is there,"
but they don't know
what's actually happening.
And they only watch TV.
They don't browse through the internet
because they think that internet is bad
and only misinformation happens there.
I think if we show actual
facts to Russian people,
to all of the Russian people,
there will be a lot less
people who agree with this.
- You know, it's really easy to tell
that somebody do not
believe what's happening,
but if they really do not believe
they can come,
they can come to the border.
Why do not they do that?
'Cause it's so easy to tell,
"I don't believe it."
- No, no, no.
- It's so easy to tell
that everything is false
but why shouldn't they
go and see by their eyes?
They don't wanna do that.
- I feel there will be
a winner in this war.
Three, two, one.
(computer beeps)
- For me, this is not a war
between Russia and Ukraine.
The actual war is between
dictatorship and freedom.
That's actually why
Putin attacked Ukraine,
I think in a nutshell.
He detests democracy,
rights, and liberties.
And I'm convinced that democracy, rights,
liberties and freedoms will prevail.
And paradoxically, and ironically,
that is perhaps the
positive outcome of this war
because this war reminded those countries
which are free, what they should value.
That they should value,
not the natural gas flowing
from Russia.
They should value the
liberties that they have,
security that they have.
And because of Ukraine, they're reminded
that it's so easy to lose all of this,
unless you stick to your principles
and to your values and
they're able to defend them.
That's why I'm pretty
optimistic that in the end
it will be a great reawakening
for those countries
which are free and why
they should stick together,
protect themselves and push
the totalitarian countries
to the brink.
- I really hope that freedom will win.
- Ukrainians and Russian
people, just normal people,
they will lose from both sides.
But talking about bigger
things, there will be like,
it's not about Russia and Ukraine.
It's about totally bigger things.
- Pretty sure I'm gonna sound very basic
but I'm gonna say it.
No one wins in wars.
It's the matter of who has more damage,
and both sides will be damaged
and are being damaged already.
And I think
that Russia's damage is
going to be more long term
because this isolation will not stop.
If in some miraculous way,
the war stops tomorrow,
this is not going to be the stop sign
for the Russian isolation.
The huge tragedy is people dying today.
And for Russia, the tragedy is not only
what's happening now, but also this,
the kind of situation that Russia is,
has ended up in already.
- There are no winners in war.
Like everything, I agree that I too hope
that the freedom will win,
that something good will
come out out of this,
like in the future.
But I think these are the consequences
not the winners of the war.
- People will be dead.
You cannot get them back.
Economies will be destroyed.
And okay, in the long run later,
we will have a winner.
We will rebuild etc,
but the damage war, any
war causes is too big.
- I would like to add
that all Russian people
that I met here have
very healthy thoughts.
- I think for Russian person
will call this all propaganda.
(Veronika chuckles)
Ukrainian propaganda.
- Yeah, I think we're
all on the same side.
- They will also say that we
are getting paid by America.
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- Thousands and thousands dollars.
- Yes.
- Yeah, We basically say the same (beep).